I I sorry Maine was where the shooting
was I said Massachusetts Maine and they
and they don't have red flag logs and
and I I hear what you're saying and
there were signs that this guy should
not have had a gun just like I believe
that people that have um are domestic
violence offenders should not have gun R
back in Texas domers can have but I'm
kind of worried about stigmatizing
people with mental health because when
you look at the statistics people that
suffer from mental health are much more
likely to be the victim ofme I know this
answer though I have mental illness
problems I have anxiety problems I have
depression problems I'm not saying
everyone that's ever gone to a therapist
or on medication he was hearing voices
that were telling him what to do I think
everyone in this room can agree that's a
mental
problem schizophrenic told people he was
going to go shoot up a base so he told
us what that that and it's important to
notice those details but we got to go
sorry we got to go we'll be right back